The year is 2025 and we're getting a lot
of Magic cards. A lot. While it's
exciting to look at the endless
spoilers, at the same time, us commander
players have to use our massive brains
more than ever. Is this card good? Does
it go into my deck? We have to repeat
this process for every card that looks
even remotely possible to not miss any
sweet tech. This is Jyn with Next Level
Commander and today we are going to look
at some new Final Fantasy cards and also
one new spoiler from Edge of Eternities.
We'll go through the evaluation process
together to see how to look at these new
cards. First, we do the easy part, the
familiar. No, not reprints, but actually
most spoilers fall into this category.
If you think a new card is something
you've never seen before, just look
closer and squint harder. It's like the
joke, everything is kicker, except it's
kind of true. is not really a joke.
Magic only has so much design space and
however creative a new mechanic is, you
can usually find a reference from the
past. Plot is like for except you pay
all the cost up front. Rooms are like
partner with except you get to choose
which one to play first. Now, this is a
good thing because it gives us an anchor
to figure out if something is worth
including along with or instead of an
older card that works in our decks.
Finding the right anchor is like 90% of
my card evaluation work. But there are
also some traps that I sometimes fall
into, which I'll talk about later. Let's
start simple. Pew pew UFO. This is easy
because it's a strict upgrade over
Walking Atlas, which isn't the best
card, but still sees play in plenty of
decks that care about Landfall or draws
a lot of cards or both. So, the process
is, do you play Walking Atlas? If you
do, play this instead. And then do you
have another card in the deck that you'd
cut for Walking Atlas? Okay, now
something a bit more complicated. Summon
Fener. Now it's a decent body with ramp,
a small pump, and potentially a card
draw if Fener sticks around. And at the
end, Fener sacks itself. Usually with
sagas, we evaluate them by the first
ability because that's the one nearly
guaranteed to trigger. The further down,
the less certain we are. Three turns is
a long time in commander. And for this
one, we are fortunate that the first
ability also happens to be the most
powerful and relevant. The card will be
much more difficult to evaluate if the
ramp ability was on say chapter 2. But
as is, we can draw a direct parallel to
Far Haven Elf. Now, this is a great
magic card, a staple even in many ETV
decks. Fenware isn't quite the same as
it isn't actually an enter the
battlefield ability, but for most lists,
it's just as good, if not better. For
example, my Git Rock Ravenous Ride deck
cares about creatures powers and this
would be close to a strict upgrade. Now,
moving on to cards that are more side
grades of past magic cards. These are
more common and can be difficult to
evaluate. Live stream's blessing. We are
no stranger to this effect. Riskards
Expertise, Return of the Wild Speaker.
These are some of the most powerful
green cards, but Liveream's blessing
does something different. Draw equal to
the greatest power among creatures you
controlled. as you cast this spell. This
line is huge. I mean, the only way your
opponents can stop this is with a
counter spell removals. Not even a
psychonic rift can stop you from drawing
the cards. The moment you cast this, the
number is locked in. And at the same
time, the forell ability is also
massive. It's just adding one to the
total cost. Since you're probably not
going to cast this on your turn anyways,
you get to gain 10 to 20 life easily,
and this can be even more relevant than
the card draw in certain situations.
But the other two predecessors do have
their upsides. Do you want that free
spellcast or the board pump over what
liveream's blessing is doing? For
example, in a Michael tyrant deck, I
might want return of the wild speaker
because while I'm going tall, I'm also
making a lot of tokens and return can be
used as a finisher. Also, I have a prime
speaker deck that is focused on beating
down with mana efficient fatties.
Enrichar's expertise will allow me to
refill my hand without skipping a beat
on applying board pressure. Let's look
at a few others. Cloud's limit break is
very far off if you compare it to the
best removals in the format. But if your
deck operates mostly at instant speed,
the six mana mode can draw some loose
comparisons to etherites. Now, this
really is a side grid because they're
not even the same colors. But in blue
white decks that play etheres, I think
cloud's limit break also deserves a
second look. Mughal's Veiler. This draws
comparisons to all the white protection
spells, even Archangel Aison at five
mana. But the closest comparison I'd say
is Grand Crescendo. Grand Crescendo is
overall a better card because of
versatility. Being able to get the base
effect for just two mana is a huge
upside, but Mugos does have higher
potential ceiling. I guess effectively
doubling your board in tokens and can be
quite good whether it's in response to a
board wipe or just at the end of an
opponent's turn. Now, I'll compare this
to another new card, restoration magic,
and restoration magic seems like a far
worse protection spell at five mana. But
actually, the curaga tier is the wrong
reference point. The correct comparison
to make here is tier one against Laurens
escape, for example, which is the most
popular protection spell in white. We
lose the scry one, but being able to
protect any permanent and doing it to
the entire board sometimes, although
inefficiently, more than makes up for
it. And after looking at some other
alternatives in white and green, also
other colors, this restoration magic
might just be the best single target
protection spell in the entire format.
Now, while we're still on the topic of
anchoring and reference points, let's
talk about some traps in evaluation that
can mislead us to over or undervalue
certain cards. The example I want to
discuss today is Blitz Bomb, the
commander sphere side grade, but I think
it's a little more complicated. Now,
before we dive into that though, I want
to ramp up with a very imaginary
example. Laura Revealed. Now, this is a
very pushed magic card that is anchored
to the NVFCs,
and it's playable pretty much in every
blue deck because we can just mindlessly
swap out an island.
Now, take a look at this imaginary card.
Island cycling three worse, but the
spell is a six- mana instant. And for
the sake of argument, draw seven. Now,
this is a ridiculous card and it's
probably much better than Laurian
revealed. However, we can't really make
the comparison because despite appearing
similar, they are completely different
cards. Our imaginary card is a draw
spell, a crazy push one at that, but it
should never replace Laurian Revealed in
any deck because it won't always be a
land when you need it to be. Now, what
if we have something in between? Island
Cycling two five mana instant speed draw
four. Now, what do we anchor this to?
Laurian revealed or the imaginary island
Cycling 3 card. Honestly, I'm not sure.
But this is also what makes card
evaluation fascinating to me. And with
that, I want to bring us the only
hottake in a video filled with what many
might consider common sense. Blissball
should not be compared to Commander
Sphere. It's actually closer to
something like Sun and Blood, a draw
spell. Now, this may sound like crazy
talk, but I think more imaginary cards
may help us see the argument. Now
imagine one day universes beyond brings
us great ball three mana add one
sacrifice this and pay two life to draw
three cards and ultra ball the same
except we can sacrifice to pay five life
to draw five cards now none of us are
going to play ultra ball as a mana rock
are we heck I'd be even afraid to tap it
for mana because if it gets blown up I
lose five cards but between commander
sphere and ultra ball at which point
does it stop being evaluated against
mana rocks and is seen as a draw spell
instead and my opin opinion is at two
cards and that's Bliss Ball. Blissball
is a three mana draw too for decks that
are desperate for card draw with some
upsides and some downsides of course,
but I imagine the best use for this
would be to power out your expensive
commander early and as soon as that
purpose is served, crack it. This is
completely different than commander
sphere, which will serve as a mana rock
until you're desperate for a last top
deck or a vendal blast gets put on the
stack. Why does this matter? because
when counting the utility in decks, this
can take up a draw slot, but Commander
Sphere can't. Now, I can't say if this
makes Blaze Ball better or worse than
Commander Sphere, but I imagine
Commander Sphere can be good in any
non-green deck, while Bliss Ball should
primarily see play in red and white,
especially if your commander costs five
or more. Traps like this are actually
quite common in Commander. Mihook
Massacre and Mihook Massacre 2 are
another great example. The original
Mihook is a decent Black Sun Xenithk
board wipe with a mediocre enchantment
attached. When you put the two effects
on the same card, it's excellent value
and super pushed. But the enchantment
itself is the weaker side. Imagine if it
was just a two- meta enchantment, you
probably wouldn't play this even in
Aristocrat decks. However, Miko Massacre
2 is the opposite. It's a solid
enchantment, a bit like my KS the
unhollowed with a crappy inefficient
board wipe attached. And again, why does
that matter? Because when evaluating, we
have to look at the original Mihook
Massacre, like an X spell, but Mihook
Massacre 2 as an enchantment. The sequel
should only be played in decks that
really want that undying effect.
Meanwhile, the original can be played in
pretty much any black deck, and it's at
its best in Aristocrats builds. And the
last trap I want to talk about today is
a new card from Edge of Eternities,
Sera, the Super Void. The immediate
comparison I drew is, of course, Grave
Pacted. But upon a closer look, this is
very different. In a deck with abundant
sack fods, Graveact will lock your
opponents out of playing creatures for
as long as it stays on the board.
Meanwhile, our black hole here is closer
to a one use spell because keeping it on
the board can be extremely difficult.
For the supervoid to do anything and
stay around, each opponent has to have
at least two creatures on the board. And
you will never touch their best
creatures unless you're willing to let
the supervoid go as well. So, in
practice, the supervoid is much closer
to a one- use board wipe in Aristocrats
text. It's got some upsides and
downsides. The biggest downside is it is
useless when you have no board. And
that's kind of when you want to wipe the
most. But the upside is flexibility. For
example, you can cast it, trigger it
after passing the turn, and your
opponents won't be casting creatures
until your next end step. It comes with
many powerful and interesting play
patterns, but it is not quite a grave
packgrade or even a downgrade. And now
we have completed the familiar cards. We
are treading into cards that we've never
seen territory. And boy, is it
treacherous. with the complexity creep.
I honestly don't know how to evaluate
some of these. I mean, just look at the
saga creatures and those where you have
to pay a hefty cost to transform them
into sagas. Oh, and these ones where you
have to choose at random. Honestly, I'm
as lost as you are. With no presidents
to compare to, these will need to be
played to evaluate properly. But where
do you play them? Well, like a drowning
man, the best I can do is to latch onto
any straw I can get. Try to find the
strongest, most consistent aspect of a
card and try to tie it to a familiar
deck or commander. Knights of the Round
uh uh it makes tokens, so I mean it
overruns, too. I guess it's fine in
token decks, but being an eight mana
enchantment is also asking to be cheated
in. So, Gen and Aminato might be
interested. That's all I got. Summon
mega sisters. uh choose one at random.
I mean, it's a five mana five5 haste.
That's a decent base. Looking at the
abilities, fight is always useful and
placing counters. It seems like a solid
card in any aggro beatd down deck or a
counters deck. At least the abilities
here have some cohesion. But then
there's ninja blades, so it makes a
ninja, but also loots. I guess maybe in
decks that care about dealing damage,
but also you want large CMC.
So, you will equip this onto maybe an
evasive commander.
Honestly, I don't know. Last one. Bam.
Guardian Seed Academy. Uh I I doubt many
decks will play enough towns to reduce
the cost even by one consistently. So,
it's a land with a mana sync late game.
I guess it's fine because I mean it's a
land but seven mana to turn this into a
vehicle. Where do we want this in a in a
vehicle deck? Simic vehicles.
I don't know. You can probably feel my
sanity waning amidst these over
complicated top- down designs. Sometimes
I feel like I'm returning to the
beginner days of card selection. No
logic, just vibes. And honestly, it
might not be a bad thing. And do you
vibe? Do you find card evaluation to be
more and more difficult nowadays? Let me
know in the comments. This is Jyn with
Next Level Commander. Please like and
subscribe. Thank you for watching. I'll
see you in the next video.